It appears Joaquin Phoenix is out to leave
a few patently unhappy faces on the Warner
Brothers bosses who financed Joker.
Though the film has danced its way to nearly
a billion dollars at the box office since
hitting theaters, Phoenix whose entrancing
performance as the deeply disturbed man behind
the iconic Batman villain has driven much
of the film's success is reportedly not quite
as on board with a return engagement as one
might think.
If his comments in a recent interview with
the Los Angeles Times are any indication,
his participation in a potential Joker sequel
is far from a given.
The actor explained,
"I guess the fear was that you'd get locked
into doing something repeatedly that you don't
really care about, that doesn't motivate you
or excite you.
Part of the whole attraction to me [of Joker]
was there was no expectation.
I didn't sign a deal to do [more films].
It was a one-off.
I wouldn't just do a sequel just because the
first movie is successful.
That's ridiculous."
The Times interview comes a full month after
the release of Joker, which has become the
highest grossing R-rated movie of all time,
is on track to join the billion dollar movie
club in the very near future, and is fully
expected to be a major player come awards
season.
Needless to say, success like that has led
to a lot of talk around a franchise-obsessed
Hollywood about whether or not there will
be a sequel to Joker.
Phoenix who's somehow managed to never appear
in any sort of sequel across a career of nearly
four decades has remained clear that a return
to the twisted mind of Arthur Fleck isn't
out of the question, but he's been just as
adamant that it'll take another truly compelling
story to get him to suit up for any Joker
sequel.
It's also pretty clear that simply flashing
some extra green in Phoenix's face won't do
the actor's statement implies he's definitely
not in it just for the money.
Still, he admitted that he had talked a bit
with Joker director Todd Phillips about a
follow-up movie, saying,
"Long before the release or before we had
any idea if it would be successful, we talked
about sequels.
In the second or third week of shooting, I
was like, 'Todd, can you start working on
a sequel?
There's way too much to explore.'
It was kind of in jest but not really."
"It seemed endless, the possibilities of where
we could go with the character."
The actor went on to share that he'd even
gone so far as to make mock posters for a
Joker followup, photoshopping the character
into some of the greatest movies of all time.
He explained,
"I basically said, 'You could take this character
and put him in any movie.'
So I did a photo shoot with the on-set photographer
and we made posters where I photoshopped Joker
into 10 classic movies: Rosemary's Baby, Raging
Bull, Yentl... if you see it, you're like,
'Yeah, I'd watch that movie.'
Yentl with Joker?
That would be... amazing!"
Director Todd Phillips seems equally ambivalent
about signing on for a follow-up film.
In the same Times piece, he insinuated that
the fate of a Joker 2 may hinge entirely on
the return of both actor and director.
The director admitted that they haven't talked
much about it at all, adding,
"We've only talked about the fact that if
we ever did one and I'm not saying we are
because right now we're not it couldn't just
be this wild and crazy movie about the 'Clown
Prince of Crime.'
That just doesn't interest us.
[...] I think the reason why [Joker is] resonating
is what's going on underneath the movie.
So many movies are about the spark, and this
movie is about the powder.
If you could capture that again in a real
way, that would be interesting."
The real question becomes whether or not Phoenix
and Phillips can find as much intrigue in
the explosion as they did in the simmering
fuse that is Joker.
Either way, the fire is still burning for
more; here's hoping that actor and director
can both find something interesting in the
flames.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.